شاب منحرف ولص محترف تاره تجده في حانه
وتاره في زنزانه لكن صورته الرسميه تضعه
في خانه وطنيه كرجل مقدر يحظى بامتيازات
غير عاديه انه الانجليزيه
فما قصته
ولد ادوارد شاب من المعروف بايدي تشاب عام
1914 في قريه انجليزيه حيث كان والده يدير
حانه محليه التحق بالجيش وهو في السابعه
عشره من عمره لكنه وبعد تسعه اشهر من
التجنيد عرب الى سوهو مع فتاه فعوقب
بالسجن وتم تسريحه بشكل مخزن عمل بعد ذلك
بمهن متفرقه قبل ان ينحرف لخط اجرامي
وينخرط في المقامره والجرائم الصغيره كما
انضم لعصابه جيلي جين التي استخدمت
القنابل في عمليه السطو
في عام
1939 قبض عليه اثناء عمليه سطو لكنه تمكن
من الهرب الى نيوجيرسي وفيما ظن انه هرب
من السجن امسكته قوات الامن هناك وسجن في
جزيره تشانيل التي وقعت في يد الالماني
عام
1940 اثناء وجوده في السجن تعاونت شاب من
مع سجين اخر وارسل الى القائد الالماني في
الجزيره عرضا بالعمل لديه كجواسيس فقبل
العرض واخضع شاب من الذي اصبح اسمه
العميله فريدز لتدريب على الجاسوسيه
بفرنسا لمده عام بعدها تم اسقاطه بالمظله
في حقل بكنبر تشير حيث سلم نفسه الى
المخابرات السريه وعرض عليهم العمل
لصالحهم ضد الالمان فاصبح عميلا مزدوجا
منذ عام
1942 في يناير عام
1943 اخبر ايدل المان هجوم سيستهدف مصنعا
للطائرات بمدينه هاتفيلد الامريكيه وكان
ذلك هجوما مزيفا قام الانجليز بترتيبه
لاقناعهم بان العميل المزدوج لا يزال نشطا
لاحقا ارسل الالمان الى النرويج التي
احتلها النازيون ليعمل مدرسا في مدرسه
للتجسس اغدق عليه الالمان الاموال وقدموا
له يختا خاصا كما منحوه الصليب الحديديه
لعمله التخريبي في وطنه لكنه بالمقابل كان
يصور الضباط الالمان وينقل الصور الى
البريطانيين
بعد غزو نورماندي ارسله الالمان الى
انجلترا لمساعده بتحديد اهداف لقنابلهم
الجديده الفي 1 وتم انزاله حينها بمظله في
انجلترا بعمليه سيئه حيث سقط على الخرسانه
وفقد بعض اسنانه هناك وصل ايدي عملته
المزدوجه وزود الالمان بمعلومات مضلله
فكان له دور كبير في تجنيب لندن القنابل
الالمانيه وتوجيهها الى ريفكنت وضواحي
الجنوب بدلا من المدينه اسهمت خدمات ايدي
لبلاده في حمايه الالاف من الارواح في عام
1948 اضطرت الحكومه البريطانيه للكشف عن
بعض الاسرار عندما مثل امام المحكمه بتهمه
تتعلق بمعامله العمله فاعطاه ضابط بوزاره
الحرب وثيقه تصفه بانه احد اشجع الرجال
الذين خدموا في الحرب الاخيره
لاحقا وفق البريطانيون على اسقاط توهم بحق
حول اكثر من اربعين جريمه كان يستحق عنها
عشرين عاما من السجن كما ظهرت سيرته في
كتابين على الاقل دبل ايجنت
من ستوري
وكذلك تم تاريخ مغامراته عام
1967 في فيلم
بعد تقاعده بالتواصل مع المجرمين كما مكث
لمده في الجزائر وشارك بعمليات التهريب
واسعه هناك قبل ان يعود الى بريطانيا
ويدير مزرعه صحيه شمال لندن
في الحادي عشر من ديسمبر عام
1997 توفي تشاب في دار للمسنين شمالي لندن
تاركا في ذاكره البريطانيين صوره مشرقه عن
ماضيه فما قدمه خلال خدمته العسكريه حوله
من لص يسرق منازل الانجليز الى بطل يستحق
الحفاوه والتكريم